the first question kind of thing which
is what's next this inflation may be
deflation where's your dry powder if you
actually did have a big Ward tomorrow
with China invading Taiwan you're going
to take it up to 200 percent uh and by
the way 130 who said that lunch table
it's Lebanon Greece and Italy I mean is
that is that the group you want to be
having lunch with you know in the
cafeteria I mean the food would be good
so you were saying to diversify which is
obviously you've said gold you've said
cash particularly in the case of
deflation and you're saying stocks and
auctions now there's a lot of people who
would look at things like Bitcoin and
would look at digital currencies
it's kind of thought control because I
using inference I can tell by what
you're reading what you're buying what
you're attending Etc kind of what you're
thinking uh combine that with artificial
intelligence and GPT technology and now
you got a Target on your back and expect
a knock on the door from the FBI goon
squads well you got to get rid of cash
and crypto hurt everybody into the
digital world then you can whack them
politically and that's what's going on
people are more obedient than I would
have expected so if those two things are
true then you run the you run the
climate change Playbook and you you get
World control
foreign
[Music]
ometry on the road from the USA I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our brilliant guest today has
been on the show about 57 times at this
point he could be the chief economic
correspondent for trigonometry gym
Rickers welcome back thank you
counseling great to be with you you are
of course uh you're of course an author
and we're going to talk about your
latest book and everything else uh as we
were joking before we started you're
always full of optimism and cheer your
latest book is called sold out how
broken supply chain surging inflation
and political instability will sink the
global economy so good news it's all
good and you are known at least to us as
the author of a number of books which
predict some pretty bad things sure and
uh you know a few of the times you've
been on the show during the pandemic I
remember we had you and our good friend
people malmgren on the show and you both
said inflation is dummy right inflation
is here what's coming now
well uh we're actually heading into
something
disinflation definition but maybe even
deflation is is the opposite at least
for the time being inflation is the end
game it has to be because there's no way
uh out from under the dead but right now
and people are still worried about
inflation prices are still going up I I
put gas in my car just like everyone
else so I'm well aware of it eggs bacon
you know Etc but inflation has been
coming down steadily since uh June of uh
of 2022. so uh about seven months in a
row eight months in a row
um it you know peaked then uh we all
know what guest prices were doing and so
forth but the reason is kind of
interesting and it does go to the the
book and the supply chain disruption
inflation uh not only prices are going
up okay so that's inflation but it can
come from two sources that are opposite
one is from uh supply side shock supply
chain disruption that's what the book is
about we saw that in 1973 with the Arab
Oil Embargo over the Arab Israeli War at
the time the price of oil quadrupled Etc
that was a supply shock the thing about
supply side inflation is it's
self-negating it burns itself out so you
know the old saying it's true the cure
for high oil prices Is high oil prices
in other words when things get too
expensive because of Supply disruption
people can't afford them businesses
close you get layoffs you go into
recession and prices come down pretty
quickly after that the other source of
inflation is from the demand side and
this is a completely different Dynamic
we saw this in the late 70s where um uh
you know prices are going up but people
have some bargaining power so unions are
on strike they're getting higher wages I
mean I worked at Citibank in the in the
late 70s early 80s they used to give us
raises without asking they say here
here's another twenty thousand dollars
because they knew that the cost of
living was going up we would all change
jobs if they didn't pay us more so but
that uh that feeds on itself so the
supplies side disruption tends to Snuff
itself out the demand side inflation
tends to feed on itself it gets out of
control and then we saw what Paul we do
with interest rates in 1980 1981 we took
them to 20 percent he he caused a
recession in terms of type monetary
policy to stop out the inflation but
otherwise if you don't do that that just
runs away now the inflation we saw in
2022 late 2021 2022 it was real it
wasn't transitory the way Jay Powell
said
um and you know the price of gasoline
doubled more than doubled and all the
other complaints you hear uh you know
the filling up before the F-150 pickup
truck went from uh 70 to 140 which for a
lot of people that meant they couldn't
eat or couldn't you know go out it was
killing demand and you know
entertainment shopping uh retail a lot
of other things which again tends to
stuff it up so that has happened to to a
great extent
starting in June 2022 that was the peak
and this inflation has been coming down
now it's still too high the fed's not
done uh we're going to see
um at least one more interest rate hike
um maybe but they're gonna leave one
more on the table we'll see what happens
in June I'm not forecasting June but I
would not rule out another interest rate
hike in June after the May hike so um
because that Jay pal is like thinking
how many times do I have to say this
he's given nine speeches since August
2022 August 26th at the Jackson Hole
then September fomc meeting on November
fomc meeting the end of November is a
speech of the Brookings institution
December fomc Congressional testimony
you know et cetera and every time he
said the same thing inflation is job one
we uh you know we we've got to get
unemployment up believe it or not they
they you know we're going to have a
recession and unemployment is going to
go up sorry about that but we've got to
get inflation under control and until we
do and that's what's under control mean
well it's two percent that's their goal
well it's come down from nine to five
nice job but five still a far cry from
Two and it gets harder as you go along
um and they're searching for what they
call the terminal rate so the terminal
rate no one knows what the number is uh
I don't know if there's Jay Pal doesn't
know but um but the terminal rate by
definition is it's a rate that's high
enough that it brings inflation down on
its own without further rate hikes
um because so far they've been raising
rates and inflation's been coming down
okay that makes sense and they can keep
raising rates then we'll come down more
but is there a level where you know
we're up we're there now we can sit
tight at the famous pause and inflation
will keep coming down now you don't know
because it's not a controlled experiment
you can't like do it twice but they're
getting close so whether it's five and a
quarter five and a half remains to be
seen but that's the terminal rate but
then Wall Street came up with this
narrative oh yeah as soon as we're done
hiking rates they're going to cut them
uh that this is the famous pivot we've
been hearing about for over a year at
this point no as far as they're
concerned forget rate Cuts in 2023 maybe
mid 2024 you'll get back to you on that
um but there's one wild card in the deck
which is
that's the fed's plan so I just gave you
the fed's game plan it's not you know
you don't know crystal ball they tell
you what they're going to do all you
have to do is listen although a lot of
people don't Wall Street makes up their
own version of that uh but uh but the
idea of Great Cuts
following hitting the terminal rate is
well rate Cuts go down so dividends
requires so buy stocks you know Wall
Street is always buy stocks that's the
that's always the punch line
but they might cut rates late in the
year not because it's their plan not
because they want to but we could be in
a very severe recession uh and that at
which point because the fed's always
late you know they're always following
the market they never leave the market
if they've already raised them they say
they may already be at the terminal rate
not know it
um and so if they keep raising which I
expect they will uh they may throw this
economy into a very severe recession
which point they may have to cut rates
not because it's in the Playbook but
because you know unemployment goes up to
seven percent and uh but that gets back
to the the first question constantly
which is what's next disinflation may be
deflation
and you mentioned however that despite
that and obviously we'll talk about the
short term and remember Jim most of our
audience are not Financial experts but
so far what they've heard from you is
it's a very unstable situation it's
going to go fluctuate wildly from one
end to the other but we're probably
going to have a recession uh and
inflation is coming down now but the
interest rates are probably going to
stay quite High correct right so that's
the the consumer take away from what
you've said but the longer term thing
and this is a recurring theme of our
discussions you said right at the
beginning of your answer which is
inflation is the only solution to the
problems that we've built up sure which
is we have these gigantic debts both the
US and the UK there's just no other way
to pay off particularly given the
gridlock of our political system where
we can't ever seem to cut spending
because cutting spending quite kills
people right well we actually had a
pretty good track record of cutting
spending for the first 220 years right
Alexander Hamilton invented the
Government Bond Market and the debate at
the time was the United States has
foreign we have a constitution George
Washington is sworn in and but we had
all these revolutionary war deaths where
we issued all these ious to fight the
Revolutionary War and they couldn't be
paid so the question is what do we do
with the Revolutionary War Death so the
Congress actually said screw them we're
not we're not paying that that was a
different country where that now the
United States of America it's the
American way
um but Alexander Hamilton said no here's
what you do borrow more money pay off
the debts you'll have good credit and
when the new money comes to you can
borrow more and pay that off and just
keep going in other words your credit is
more valuable than uh you know writing
off a bunch of uh creditors at one time
because you ruined your credit so he
said borrow more and establish your
credit and then just keep it going and
that was the creation of the Government
Bond Market and that's been going strong
for for 200 years but I studied this and
the pattern was very consistent the
United States would run up the debt to
fight a war every war war of 1812
obviously the Civil War or some
Mexican-American war Civil War
Spanish-American War World War One World
War II every time we ran out the debt we
fought we paid the War uh paid for the
war won and then after the war we took
the debt back down again so it was never
it never went straight up it's not a
straight line from George Washington to
Joe Budden it's a it's a sideway up and
down and up and down we did a very good
job of paying off the debt in times of
Peace so you'd have dry powder in effect
so you could run up the debt in Wartime
um and the class it's a tool it's a tool
you use to deal with the challenges of
the moment but then the most important
thing is you put the tool back in the
box and you polish it and you get it
ready for the next time sharpen up
sharpen it up get it ready for this and
that's why there's so much confusion
about John Mayer Keynes I believe chains
was one maybe the best or second or
third best after Irving fisher maybe
Economist of the 20th century but
keynesianism is bankrupt neocasianism it
was really bastardized by Paul Simonson
at MIT after the war came World War II
case died in 1946
um so Paul Samuel said others the big
brains at MIT they had spent World War
II as Logistics experts doing linear
programming before computers uh that had
some machines but you know but you know
we're going to D-Day okay where the
supply is coming from where's the
where's the fuel coming from where's the
ammunition coming from uh what's the
best way to deploy bombers Etc and they
solved all those problems so then in
peace they said well we can take all
those wonderful tools we developed to
win World War II and apply them to
economics and we'll start with Keynes
but we'll actually turned into a machine
we can fine-tune the economy I remember
the phrase in the 60s or no more
recessions they used to say because we
can fine tune the economy that was all
before it ran off the rails in the 1970s
I don't blame Kane's to that because he
he was not an idea he was a pragmatist
he believed in doing whatever worked and
in a depression in a liquidity trap when
people were hoarding money hoarding gold
not spending it he said well people
won't spend the government can and get
the economy moving but then he was the
first one to say yeah once you get there
pay it back and then you let the economy
run on its own same idea so the classic
case end of World War II the U.S debt to
GDP ratio by the way Constantine um
people said we have a big debt you know
if you throw out you know 25 trillion 31
trillion no one understands this well
they don't but I don't care here's what
I mean by that the number doesn't mean
anything what you have to calculate is
the debt to GDP ratio what is your
payment ability so I say if I if I owe
you know fifty thousand dollars on a
MasterCard and I'm making twenty
thousand dollars a year I'm probably
going broke if I owe 50 000 and I'm
making half a million a year I can write
a check so notice that the debt can only
be considered dangerous or not in
relation to the income so you look you
want to look at the debt to GDP ratio in
1945 the U.S statute GDP ratio was 120
all-time high what does that mean Jim
well it means that it's extremely high
and you have to pay it off but my point
is we won the war and we were a global
hegemon we I remember being in
elementary school U.S producers half
half the cars three quarters of the cars
in the world half the iron like hey we
got the whole thing we won the war but
then what happened next was even more
interesting between 1945 and 1980 that
debt to GP ratio went down from 120 to
30 percent which is completely
manageable and it was bipartisan you had
Democrats like Harry Truman JFK and
Lyndon Johnson Jimmy Carter Republicans
like Eisenhower Nixon and Ford it was
not a partisan issue everybody thought
it was a good idea and then so Along
Comes Reagan he's handed a debt to GDP
ratio of 30 percent now Reagan has his
reputations you know tight tough fist
you know with tight fisted conservative
no he ran it back up again to 50 percent
but we won the Cold War and we won
another War we you know in 1989 the
Berlin Wall comes down 1991 the
dissolution of the Soviet Union and I
know there was George H.W bush but
Reagan laid the groundwork with Star
Wars and Lotus so um it's okay rounding
up again but we won the Cold War which I
never thought would end I thought I'd
you know good next 50 years be talking
about the Cold War so but then you're
supposed to take it down again and that
didn't happen under George H.W bush and
Bill Clinton they didn't run it up but
they didn't take it down the state
around 50 60 percent and even under
George W bush with Iraq and everything
else it didn't go much above that but
where it exploded was Obama and Trump uh
and and Biden so Obama was handed about
105 between uh Obama and Trump they took
it up to 131 percent which is where it
is now and in Biden as well so they
broke the mold that 220 year mold I just
described there were no probably no
existential Wars yeah we're we're in a
kind of a long drawn-out thing in
Afghanistan but it wasn't nearly as
costly as the other things we're talking
about uh the US didn't win anything by
the way but they rounded up to 130
percent now that's first of all the
highest of all time secondly it broke
the world that you should pay it down in
times of peace third uh where's your dry
powder if you actually did have a big
war tomorrow with China invading Taiwan
you got to take it up to 200 percent uh
and by the way 130 who said that lunch
table it's Lebanon Greece and Italy I
mean is that is that the group you want
to be having lunch with you know in the
cafeteria I mean the food would be good
yeah
the food is pretty good but uh yeah
maybe we could pay for it in Lira but uh
but that's but that's where we are so
this is uh untrusted and it's never been
this High it breaks the pattern of
running it up in war and paying it down
a piece no one roots for war but they
happen
um and uh and it's worse than that
because of modern monetary Theory here's
where my friend Stephanie Kelton comes
in she's a professor at the University
of New York uh Stony Brook campus uh
she's the big brand of mmt and she was
an economic advisor to Bernie Sanders
when he was on the Senate budget
committee and in both of his campaigns
2016 2020
um again her book the deficit myth I
highly recommend it I disagree with
every word but uh if you want to win the
debate or you want to understand what's
going on you you have to read her book
and I never put words in anyone's mouth
these are her words
she says what's the problem you the
vacuum print unlimited amounts of money
which is true the treasury cannot uh
issue unlimited amounts of debt not
quite true you have to raise the debt
ceiling but it always has been raised so
that's never acted as a constraint
um she says yes right from her book she
said the only reason we have a bond
market is a favor to investors to give
them a place to put their money we don't
actually need to borrow any money all
you have to do you want to buy 10 F-35
Jets give the FED wire instructions a
Lockheed just wire them the money what
what's this business up here issuing
debt and having Underwriters and primary
dealers and treasury gets the money they
deposit the fed and they they pay
Lockheed just cut out all the middle man
just have the FED wire the money
directly to Lockheed
um and uh so yeah so and we don't even
need a tax system we have it because
we're trying to engineer income equality
but we don't actually need taxes or
bonds because we can just print the
money and send it wherever we want
what's the problem well when you frame
it that way you actually start started
out agreeing with her man I'm a lawyer I
dealt with the FED for decades it was
once physically threatened by a Fed
official they started to come across the
table at me but that was back in the day
where they were a lot tougher than they
are today it's a Irish guy very well
known
um but uh but I do what he said uh so um
but but the point is the Fed actually
can print unlimited a massive money that
is the law uh the treasury can issue all
the debt at once subject to you know
debt ceiling increases that's the law
and you can send the wires uh so so why
not
so this is one of these issues where I
knew that it wasn't right I knew this is
really bad advice I knew that modern
monetary Theory will fail but uh I
didn't immediately know how to rebut
those points because she's right
um so I said well the failure must lie
elsewhere it must be not that you can't
print the money or you can't send the
money to Lockheed it there must be
something else and here's where I
arrived at I was trying to crack the
code on bitcoin that took 10 years also
um
people say well Bitcoin is not backed by
anything where the dollar is not backed
by anything or the euro is not backed by
anything and I say yes they are they're
all backed by the same thing which is
confidence right if I think something's
money and you think it's money and I
tender it to you for goods and services
and you think you're confident you can
give it to Francis for goods and
services and we have a large enough
group it's money right it could be we
were kids we did this with baseball
cards and bottle caps you know so
anything can be money if there's
confidence but confidence is fragile
it's easily lost and when you lose it
it's very very difficult to regain and
I've had this debate I've been in vaults
in the Pentagon you know we're doing a
tabletop Financial war game and like 10
people sitting around the table here's
the treasury and the CIA and the
three-star General and
um you know a couple thing tank people
and we're we're doing this and I told
the Pentagon well the group but
including the treasury this seven or
eight years ago because we were
weaponizing the dollar against Iran yeah
don't get me started in Russia well
actually I'll start myself in Russia but
um the point is I said sanctions work to
a point you're weaponizing the dollar
but you're doing it too much too
frequently and you're relying on it too
much and what's going to happen is
you're going to drive people away from
the dollar you're going to drive people
out of the dollar system because they're
not going to take it anymore I was
um well this one guy was sitting in one
place away from me there was somebody in
between us
um he was a very senior treasury
official specifically tasked with
managing foreign exchange relationships
with um with Asian Japan and China
basically uh the senior guy
his name was actually David dollar but
he takes both hands slams among table
the dollar is the global Reserve
currency it always has been the global
Reserve currency and it will always be
the global Reserve currency
and I said David I feel like I'm in
Whitehall in 1913 listening to John bull
say you know Sterling is the global
Reserve currency and it always will be
and of course it was dead by 1944.
started to die in as early as November
1914 at the beginning of World War One
so um so I've worn them I've explained
it to them but now we're at the point
where that's actually happening the
kinds of things I describe so it's like
you you hit The Punchy bag you hit it
you hit it you hit at some point the
punching bag itself and walks away it's
like I'm not going to stand for this and
the the key thing there's always a uh
you know snowflake that starts the
Avalanches I described
um was when we froze the reserves of the
Central Bank of Russia
Another War on got it Financial
sanctions yeah they were probably
inevitable but Russia's not Syria uh
it's the uh largest landmass in the
world it's the largest nuclear Arsenal
in the world
um it's the 12th largest economy in the
world it has the best gold to GDP ratio
in the world which is another metric we
talk about but if you want to back up
your economy with real money uh their
their goal to GDP ratios four times what
the United States says
um the list of strategic medals uh grain
exports uh oil of course this is
fertilizer nitrates
Etc that they export and they're only
one of only two countries the other big
France that will give you a nuclear
technology if you want to build a
nuclear not a weapon but a nuclear power
plant the US is kind of out of that game
so it's not some punk country
um and they had over
150 billion dollars in U.S treasury
notice they've been they've been getting
away from
and Avira nebulina who's the head of the
Central Bank of Russia she's she's the
only Central Bank of the world who knows
her job she very prudently uh has
quadrupled the Russian gold Reserve
since 2009 so 13 14 years uh she's taken
it from 600 tons to close to 3 000 tons
they did it very transparently they had
dealers in London they had standing
orders they said we don't want to
disrupt the market
by the way don't try calling up and
ordering 400 tons of gold you'll be
they'll just hang up the phone but you
know 10 tons a month sometimes 30 times
a month but for over 10 years it added
up to the position and today guess what
it's physical gold it's in safe storage
near Moscow you can't it's not digital
you can't freeze it you can't seize it
it's it's but it's money good
um but we
um confiscated or froze their U.S
treasury Securities because they're they
are digital there hasn't been a paper
treasury security since 1980.
um and The Ledger is maintained by the
uh Federal Reserve in the treasury
by the way keep that in mind if we talk
about Central Bank digital currencies
because you're back to who who runs the
Ledger but for U.S treasury Securities
that that um ledgers digital is running
the United States
you know people you know we're in a debt
ceiling debate right now the Congress is
debating raising the debt ceiling and uh
if you didn't do anything you know the
x-state when the treasury actually goes
broke and we default on the debt
everyone's all spun up about this the US
defaults us that all the time uh and and
people don't seem to notice but if
you're Russia and you buy treasury notes
and bills in good faith and they're
supposed to pay as agreed at maturity
and all of a sudden the issuer says
sorry I'm not paying you
if that's not a default I don't know
what it is you know maybe selective
maybe I'm just picking on you and not
the whole Market but that's the default
1933 when Roosevelt devalued the Dollar
by 75 and took gold from uh 20 down to
35 an ounce uh confiscated all the gold
and some papers paper money was no no
longer redeemable in the gold that's the
default I mean that's the default
because treasury Securities at the time
used to have a gold equivalent and FDR
just tore it up so and then 1977 to 1981
inflation was 50 in all my Austrian
libertarian friends you know they go
well since 1913 the dollar has lost 95
of his purchasing power which is true
but so what I mean incomes are higher
but there was a five-year period not a
hundred years where the dollar lost 50
percent of its purchasing power which
meant if you hold if you held a bond the
real value of your bond was cut in half
that's a default see there's just like
lots of different ways to default the US
does it all the time getting back to
your other question Constantine about
inflation being being the real end game
so anyway
so we pushed Russia and by the way
Russia's held up very well their economy
is going to outperform the United States
in 2023 uh according to the IMF and
others um World Bank
um they're uh the RuPaul is strong it
was for a long time stronger than it was
before the War uh you know so they're
they're you know they're feeling the
pain I'm not saying there's no pain at
all but they're getting through it
brilliantly and they're going to
outperform the us this year but um but
the rest of the world took notice so
let's say you're China or Saudi Arabia
or turkey or Brazil or you know and then
these are major countries
um they're saying hey the US just froze
the reserves in Central Bank of Russia
what if you know Janet Yellen gets out
of the wrong side of the bed and uh
frightening thought but uh um says they
don't like me they don't like my policy
they don't like what I'm doing in Taiwan
or
um uh the Kurds or uh you know women's
right whatever pick a topic they could
do that to me and so people are like
okay now we really do have to get out of
the dollar not as a an economic matter
but as a national security manner from
their perspective so Jim we've been
talking at the macro level now but I
want to focus in on the ordinary
American the ordinary British person
they're looking at an economy which is
lurching like you said from one end
extreme to the other right they're
looking at their savings being depleted
they're looking at prices going through
the roof what should they do in order to
weather the storm that is coming within
the next few months well there is a lot
they can do
and I'm going to give you an answer and
everyone rolls their eyes to go that's
obvious the answer is diversification
everyone goes oh we know that you know
diversification but they know the term
but they actually don't know what
diversification is and I'll give you an
example I run into people all the time
they go well Jim I'm fully Diversified I
have 50 stocks in 10 different sectors
telecommunications semiconductors
consumer non-durables metals and Mining
and I go you're not Diversified you may
have 50 stocks but you're in one asset
class called stocks or equities and
they're all going to go up together or
they're all going to go down together
and the more stressful the condition the
more reason you have to be concerned
about it the higher the correlation you
know at any given day some stocks go up
and stocks go down but when you dial the
stress meter up they all tend to move
together so that's I don't care about
your 50 stocks your 10 sectors that's
not Diversified so what does real
diversification look like have a sleeve
of equities if you want that's fine I
would say I look hard at oil Natural Gas
US national resources agriculture again
kind of equities that have hard assets
behind them that will do well in
inflationary times or even in
recessionary times because you need all
those things no matter what
um then a slice of real estate you know
I wouldn't be in commercial real estate
but you know residential real estate
income producing real estate Farms Etc
that's good I have a big slug of cash
and people go well cash doesn't have an
EO well lately deals you can get uh two
three percent you know on like a CD but
even in a simple savings account
um you know it is quite low it's kind of
less than one percent but people don't
understand the value of cash in a couple
of respects number one in a deflationary
environment we're not there yet but we
could hit that if the recession gets bad
enough cash could be your best
performing asset it doesn't go up in
nominal terms but it goes up in real
terms if you have two percent deflation
your cash is worth two percent more in
terms of purchasing power but the but
the real value cash is
optionality and this is not well
understood I shared an office with Myra
Schultz for six years so I see Options
under the pillow so to speak but uh
um if you're the one with cash when
things first of all it'll definitely
preserve well so if things are falling
all around you your cash will be what
it's worth unless you're in Silicon
Valley Bank it's a separate issue but um
although they got bailed out uh but so
it'll preserve wealth even if it's not a
high performer it'll do very well in
deflation but the real benefit is when
everything else is falling apart you're
the one who can go shopping so it's kind
of an at the money call option every
asset class in the world you know
everyone's selling everything in a panic
you can bite your time watch it go down
look for a bottom and then say okay now
I'll buy these things down 30 or 40 or
50 from where they were
some Alternatives I um uh you know I
have a number of investments in uh you
know private equity and Venture type
situations and yeah they're risky and
then liquid but some of them will do
very well some of them have done well so
that's nice and then a slice of gold and
I recommend 10 uh because people you
know they put washing your mouth they go
Jim Baker says sell everything and buy
gold I've never said that not a good
strategy but 10 yeah first of all
there's your inflation hedge
um but also it's a money hedge meaning
if going back to what we said earlier
about confidence uh see I've said all
along that Russia China Iran uh you know
I don't care who they are they can't
destroy the US dollar but the US can we
are Our Own Worst Enemy Janet Yellen is
the greatest enemy of the dollar because
the way she's throwing sanctions around
she may destroy confidence
um and um the reason like hey if the
dollar is so shaky or you know there's
all this downside by being invested why
don't I go to another Reserve currency
there aren't any
this is um
this is a key distinction that gets it
gets glossed over in the debate you see
people on TV all the time talking about
you know Saudi Arabia is doing a Chinese
Yuan deal with China or uh Brazil is
doing a bilateral deal with China and
you know in Yuan and rice and there's no
dollars involved but they and that's the
end of the dollar as a reserve currency
people are not people do not distinguish
between a payment currency and a reserve
currency two different things payment
currency is anything you're willing to
accept or I'm willing to accept uh and
it's important and that that's where the
dollar is under attack Watch What
Happens in August the bricks plus they
got a 19-member waiting list they're
going to be more than half the global
population more than half Global GDP in
a matter of months
um they are working on their own payment
currency payment channels Etc uh they
haven't announced what it is yet but
they're working on it all these other
countries have mentioned doing bilateral
deals uh sharing High cooperation
organization is working on an alternate
currency but all those deals are payment
currencies and again you can use
baseball cards if everybody's in on the
deal Reserve currency is different
because there actually are no Reserve
currencies you know People's Bank in
China doesn't have pallets of hundred
dollar bills in the basement it's a
reserve is a security denominated in a
currency
so people say 60 of global reserves are
in dollars they're in U.S treasury
Securities denominated dollars the key
to the reserve currency is the security
not the dollar well although it is
denominated in dollars but just holding
on there a second gym so you're saying
to diversify which is obviously you've
said gold you've said cash particularly
in the case of deflation and you're
saying stocks and options now there's a
lot of people who would look at things
like Bitcoin and would look at digital
currencies look at Jim's face
I know you're a big Bitcoin guy Jim
you're a huge fan huge fan of could you
please explain to people why
particularly this applies to younger men
who see these types of cryptocurrencies
as a shortcut to wealth and to generate
money for themselves right why this
might not be a good idea well uh sure
I've spent uh I've been dragged into a
whole bunch of gold versus Bitcoin big
base and to me it's like you know fish
versus bicycles like it's they're two
separate things yeah
um but when if I'm gonna be the gold
side and debate somebody on the Bitcoin
side I'm going to be certain to know
more about it than they do I don't want
any surprises so I've actually studied
Bitcoin from the beginning I read uh
Satoshi nakamoto's paper like less than
a year after it came out I've studied it
very closely ever since
um and I
I guess it's been 10 years working on
the problem like there is no there there
so but I see the price action I know
people who bought Bitcoin at two bucks
and sold out of twenty thousand and
um you know paid their taxes like good
citizens and walked away with 20 million
dollars you know those those stories are
real they're also suicides from people
who bought Bitcoin and seventy thousand
dollars and went to 15 and they'd hark
their inventory and they're out of
business and and committed suicide so
that's the other side of the trade but
yeah the the the the the profit making
stories are real we can all look at the
price action it was 68
000 in November 2021 that was a real
number I talked to Mark sailor he was he
had made about six billion at that point
I think he's he was underwater briefly
he's back up to a billion he lost 5
billion when I went down to uh 13 000.
that's rallied recently I get all that
but but I'm like
what is it and why um so I've come up
with two explanations actually if I work
on this year for 10 years or so and I
saw that I I move on I'm like okay I got
to I don't have to think about it
anymore because they solved the problem
um
and uh so so here's the thing on bitcoin
the best way to understand it if I go
into you know the Wynn Hotel in Las
Vegas I Put you know five thousand
dollars down the roulette table it could
be gives me a big stack of chips and I
gamble and I can make money or I could
lose money I know the the odds and all
that I'm working on a roulette system
says everybody but
um you can make or lose money but let's
say you make money okay you can't take
those chips and walk out on the
Boulevard and buy dinner you have to go
to the cashier and change them for
dollars and then you can take your
dollars and treat your friends to dinner
whatever you want and notice there's a
portal between crypto world and the and
the main banking world or the Dollar
World or Euros or anything else that you
have to go through in order to find any
utility in the sense of money
um so uh I've I've thought of it as a
casino chip where the the crypto or
other Bitcoin I know ether and ripple
and all these other ones uh they're the
casino you can go and put your dollars
up get your chips gamble make money or
lose money but you can't go anywhere
else you can't do anything else you're
just in the casino and if you want to
get out of the casino and do that back
in the real world you got to go to the
cashier now interesting footnote on that
on March 10th the uh this is funny the
FDIC shutdown Silicon Valley Bank and uh
not to get too far afield but when they
did it they followed the Brisbane
Australia November 2014 bail in rules
remember after 2008 what happened in
2008 the FED bailed out everybody so
Jamie Diamond kept his job all these
guys kept their jobs they got their
bonuses they didn't lose anything else
the stock market went down but it came
back
um nobody was held accountable nobody
went to jail they all made more money
than ever they kept their bonuses and
the and the taxpayers you know your
everyday American or every day uh uh a
British subject is sitting there saying
wait a second I finance this and you
guys got rich and I didn't get anything
except my retirement uh you know a
counselor blew up
so the elites were aware of that they
said we can't let that happen again
there will be other Financial panics so
in Brisbane the G20 came up with the
bail in plan they said okay we're not
going to deal with taxpayer money we
can't the people won't tolerate it so
when an institution fails here's what
happens Equity gets wiped out I think I
need bankruptcy Equity gets wiped out
bondholders get wiped out to the extent
there's a hole in the balance sheet you
might get 20 cents on the dollar or
whatever and then we're going to turn to
depositors and if you have an insurance
scheme we're going to pay the insurance
250 000 in the U.S I believe it's a
hundred thousand Euros in the EU UK has
something similar we're going to pay
that but that's it and then we're going
to whack the depositors and they're
going to suffer and not until every
every uh uh credit or deposit or
whatever has been hit will we even think
about using taxpayer money so that's the
bail in U.S deposits are billed into
saving the institution as opposed to a
government bailout well there were no
major failures between two thousand 14
and and 2023. so here we are March 10
2023 the FDIC gets out the bail in
Playbook and says okay uh equities gone
uh the insured deposit is being paid 250
your money will be good Monday morning
no problem and all you other depositors
you 140 billion dollars of depositors
you're wiped out
they didn't say we're freezing your
accounts or we'll get you know they said
you're gone and
um they gave them a receivership
certificate because the company was
technically put into receivership you
got a receivership certificate
um what was it worth no idea when will I
get cash we're working on it we'll sell
the assets and we'll pay you as and when
we get proceeds we'll pay you but we
don't know when and RTC in 1990 same
kind of deal
um took two years I thought they did a
good job I was doing deals with drtc we
were sitting on boxes because their
Furniture hadn't arrived yet but they
were they were Wheeling a deal and
trying to get the stuff out the door
well all the billionaire crybabies spent
the weekend banging on the White House
door saying you know you can't do this
this is entrepreneurs over Silicon
Valley this is their startup Capital
they can't meet payroll they can't pay
the rent you know you're going to shut
down technology et cetera et cetera
um you can't do this basically so
um the first time was six o'clock Friday
at 6 p.m on uh Sunday the 12th the FDIC
and the FED came out with a statement
said just kidding all the deposits are
good unlimited amounts I know a guy was
moving 8 billion out of it he said he
told me he said we put the wire
instructions on Thursday but from
Thursday to Sunday we didn't know where
the money was and nobody did but it came
through
um one of the crypto exchanges had 3
billion and uh um I think the circle uh
the one that backs uh one of the stable
coins they had three billion but the
cost they had Cisco uh Roku um uh Etsy
uh they had a ton of big names in there
and then the whole startup thing was a
bit of a fraud because first of all most
startups fail anyway so you were just
kind of accelerating the timeline but um
it was a climate bank and that's why the
White House came because these were not
new apps or new you know
cryptocurrencies or things that maybe
make life a little bit simpler it was
all climate change they were working on
Battery Technology wind turbines you
know better chemistry carbon capture Etc
there is no climate crisis that's that's
made up uh to you know we're on a
separate agenda of world control
um but that's who was in it of course if
you're at the White House the greenish
scam is your number one priority so
that's why they got bailed out so so
they just took the bail in thing and
tore it up threw it away uh ensured all
the depositors they did more than that
they they the FED created a facility
they would take every underwater bond in
the country if you're a member bank and
give you par so if your Bond's worth 80
they'll give you 100 I wouldn't mind
getting it on that deal for one year low
interest and I'm sure it'll extend it
when the year's up so that's that's kind
of the world
um we're living in today and then people
don't know about if their deposits are
insured or not it depends if you're Bank
systemically important according to
Johnny Allen and that's undefined
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be canceled culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
right I was gonna talk about Supply
chains but you did mention the the
non-existent climber crisis and that
it's it's a ploy for World control and
this is what I we hear this argument
from people a lot and you you and I had
a few messages about my Oxford speech
that you understand how I feel about you
know if we're if we're being told that
that you know Carbon is the problem why
are we doing things that don't seem to
really do anything about that so so I
get what you're saying but I always get
wary when people get into the sort of
like there's a a group of people who
secretly have an agenda uh now we see
with the Davos people whatever they all
believe this stuff and they all think
it's important and and because they
think it's important they think uh a
global problem requires Global Solutions
correct but are you saying that these
aren't just a bunch of you know slightly
deluded well-intentioned people but
actually they don't believe the thing
that they're saying in the first place
some of them do the less intelligent
ones do um yeah the John Curry's and the
Al gors and uh
um you know and you've got some True
Believers you know juliant has you know
been knocked heads with her a few times
um if the financial times
um but some of them do but the vast
majority of Americans obviously people
you know Western Europe maybe even more
so who buy into this
you ask him a simple question like and
what percentage of the atmosphere is CO2
have no idea
um do you know the CO2 the main reasons
around is plant food if you get rid of
CO2 all the plants will die and we'll
start it no I didn't think of that uh
it's poison really I just exhale some
CO2 sorry I didn't mean to poison the
room I mean they these people don't know
anything about chemistry they don't know
anything about physics they don't know
their climate I mean I I am a complexity
theorist my
um ability to kind of understand Capital
markets is based on applying complexity
theory if over here in the physics World
bringing it to Capital markets they are
complex Dynamic systems nonpareil so and
it works beautifully but probably the
most complex system you can think of is
is the climate is climatology and so
there's kind of a reign of terror going
on in that world where you know this guy
at Penn State you know he's his big
thing uh is just to sue you mentioned
his name uh but let's not mention we're
not as rich as you remember Jim well
yeah he's backed by the state of
Pennsylvania so um but we're not Jim
exactly so but my point is my point is
they will um so you're an up and coming
climate researcher or a physicist or
whatever you will not get a tenure you
will not get published you will not get
research grants if you deviate in any
way from The Narrative which is that CO2
is poison methane is poison there's
um if global temperatures go up whatever
what is 1.5 Centigrade before a certain
time the oceans are going to rise New
York City Subways will be flooded none
of that is true there is no evidence
that shows conclusively the CO2 has
anything to do with global warming
number one uh you can speculate on it is
it is greenhouse gas it does trap
um heat but the system is so complex
that other factors come into play that
tend to that tend to reverse have
recursive functions and tend to reverse
whatever it was to the start of it the
causes of climate change are actually
very well known
sun cycles volcanoes ocean currents the
location of the jet stream there are
there are a set of factors you know La
Nina El Nino uh that uh you know Oceanic
subduction where you know cold is it
warms more warm saltier water from the
Gulf Stream gets up near Iceland and uh
it goes under the fresh water but
sometimes it doesn't and then that'll
make it warmer there and because it just
streamed to dip and be colder in Europe
Etc the medieval warm period from around
about the 10th Century to the uh the
12th century they were growing grapes in
Greenland I mean they had Farms they had
colonies and then today they're all
under ice the little Ice Age which
wasn't a true Ice Age but it was a
intense period of global cooling the
tents was frozen they didn't need the
bridges you could work across the Thames
on ice and they have what they call
Frost fairs in the early 17th century
London where they the merchants would
set up their boots on the on the times
that people would go out ice skating and
you could go shopping that's how cold it
was and that that lasted for several
hundred years so of course the climate
changes you know and say you know you're
a climbing scenarios I'm not climates
and our climates change all the time I
just denied bad science I deny your hoax
I deny your lies that's yeah all right
well this video is not demonetized
thanks to you Jim but but you know it is
it's weird because
uh matters of science you you could be
completely wrong about this right I'm
not saying you are but you could be and
we should still be able to have the
conversation but if it does feel like to
me I feel it inside is hosting the show
right now I feel like I have to sort of
acknowledge the fact that you've
expressed a controversial view that goes
against
what we all are supposed to I I have not
expressed an opinion everything I've
said is based on science I can be happy
to Pardon Me Deluge you with the with
the peer review papers what's
interesting is that this the the true
experts I'm talking about you know
Princeton physicists University Colorado
by the way they're very other top
research universities in this field the
guys and women mostly guys who are
retired who aren't worried about all the
things they're writing papers that
completely refute the climate change
narrative I should I should call it the
global warming CO2 narrative because
everyone anyone who knows anything knows
that climate's changed I lived 10 years
on Long Island let's not spend too long
on this because I just wanted to to
point that out but the thing I really
wanted to talk about as well uh James is
one of the things that defined the
politics of the last
eight to nine years I would argue is
globalization and the impact that that
process had on particular subsets of our
population correct and the brexit and
Trump
votes had a lot to do with that yes and
part of the way that they impacted
politics was that
this is the argument I don't know
whether you agree with it but people
would argue globalization wasn't that
good in terms of making everybody richer
around the world however it had you
don't agree with this part well let me
let me get the rest
however it had a very bad impact on
certain groups of the population in
certain countries in the west that meant
that basically lower skilled people lost
their jobs in manufacturing jobs in
particular and around the world it meant
you know people working in terrible
conditions and blah blah blah and that's
not necessarily may still have been an
improvement on what they were doing
before but that's right right now
what we saw as a result of covid
and other things to do with the pandemic
and now the war in Ukraine the world is
going through a process of
de-globalization correct and this is
what you this is what you call broken
supply chains that's basically what that
means right yeah the program Supply
chains are a part of it and that's going
to continue and we are deglobalizing or
decoupling is another word but it's the
same thing we're busting up
globalization so does that my question
to you is does that not mean that we're
all gonna well except for the super rich
we're always going to get richer it
seems like we're all going to get poorer
now well when you going back to what you
said the government zero kind of thing
where you know whether the winners or
losers Etc and of course there were uh
we're all better off
that's true on average average is hide
more than they reveal you have to get
behind the average and look at the
degree distribution so you know so the
old joke I have to use cliches but I'll
use one now you know 20 guys are in a
bar and Bill Gates Works in it on
average everyone's a billionaire right
well you're actually the same guy you
were before you walked in the bar so um
you can't do whatever you want but to me
it's not meaningful to talk about uh
higher average income higher per capita
income without looking at the degree
distribution the genie coefficient the
income inequality that's where it
matters because I spent a lot of time in
China um the the sliver of the
population who are multi-billionaires
um is brings up the average but so yeah
okay people left the farm they went to
the city uh it's still rough but it's
better than where they were and they are
better off I don't I don't dispute that
but you can't look at the average
numbers or the global numbers uh without
understanding the fact the people are a
little bit better off some of them but
the the income the income inequality is
Extreme and it's also extreme the US uh
Genie coefficient is a measure of income
inequality so higher number means you're
more unequal uh the U.S just passed
Mexico I mean Mexico is always the for
Americans at least so this they you got
oligarchs in Mexico well we got them
here and we got plenty of them so um
first of all real incomes of uh
Americans have been declining for
um uh 30 years for for working class
Americans now the super rich yeah
they're off the charts uh so the average
is still look bad by the way but they
don't look um as bad as the everyday
American who has been in a losing race
for 30 years but yes a small sliver
they're much better off uh and they're
the ones with the biggest interest in
keeping the game going but I also I also
disagree Constantine when you said um
you know to secret caban you didn't
quite put it that way but that was sort
of uh you know aren't we in the
conspiracy theory land sounds
I can name them all you know it's it's
Christine Lagarde and Johnny Owen and
Tim Gaither and Mark Carney probably the
number one villain in the whole thing
um uh you know the the Tim Cook Jeff
Bezos you're the heads of the major tech
companies Mark Zuckerberg uh the Davos
crowd but but more than that uh and they
totally get it these are you know these
are smart people in addition to being
immensely powerful but they want this
because sorry Jim what do they want they
well what they want and I talk about
this in my book the road to ruin uh 2016
book The Road To Rule and I explained
this in in great detail probably being
10 years ahead of your time is it when
it comes true everyone forgot you send
it but pick up that book and you'll
you'll get the blueprint
um look what they want in nutshell is
World Government World money World
taxation with a small group in control
that's what they want the question is
how do you get there the answer is and
and Carl popper explained this uh 70 80
years ago and George Soros adopted it uh
it's called Uh piecemeal social
engineering it's like slicing a salamity
salami don't take the whole thing it
wants to slice slice slice people don't
notice or give yourself enough time and
you'll eventually get to where you want
to be so the Euro was a big step in that
direction uh because it no more Lira no
more chocolate no more pesetos uh French
francs
um and now you know NAFTA it was a big
step in that direction you know more you
know no more borders so they want to
eliminate borders they want to eliminate
different kinds of money the uh the
Central Bank digital currencies even if
you do it you know this is cbdc Euro
it's not it's not a cryptocurrency by
the way it's the message traffic is
encrypted it is digital but it's not a
cryptocurrency because there's a single
Ledger controlled by the government they
can see what you're doing this is the
ultimate
um social control tool
where are they traveling how are they
traveling what are they eating what are
they consuming on the platform so
individual carbon footprint tracker stay
tuned we don't have it operational yet
but this is something that we're working
on
so right now I'm in an airport I want a
candy bar I go to a retail place I buy a
candy bar I use a credit card the
merchant how does he get paid well he
sells that receivable to somebody called
a merchant acquirer these are factoring
businesses that buy up hundreds of
millions of dollars of receivables so
the merchant gets paid then the merchant
acquirer delivers it to Mastercard or
VISA he gets paid MasterCard Visa
distributes it to the issuing Banks they
get paid the bank sends me a bill and I
pay the bank okay why do we need five
intermediaries and three percent
discount three percent of fees for me to
buy a candy bar uh so the Central Bank
digital currency where you have a single
Ledger you know QR code on your on your
smartphone no intermediaries
um it's better faster cheaper and that's
true that's actually true they always
sell stuff by giving you the benefits
they never tell you the other side the
other side is
um oh no I'm in a bookstore I buy the
new book by Rhonda sanus you know well
right now that's between me and
MasterCard you need under the Fourth
Amendment you need a subpoena and a
warrant to get that information from
MasterCard and if you're not a wrongdoor
they should be able to get it but with
essential Bank digital currency the uh
the government knows that they know I
bought a book by around the sentence
they know I gave a contribution to Elise
stefanik who's the number three
Republican in the house
um they know I I travel to you know
Florida you know Red State whatever I
mean and then you combine what I just
said that ledger with um artificial
intelligence with the GPT uh generative
pre-trained Transformer technology you
got a Target on your back but that
information which the government will
now have firsthand they're not stealing
it you're giving it to them by using
their Central Bank digital currency
combined with
um uh GPT uh artificial intelligence
technology they can develop a profile of
you and go back to
um Joe Biden's speech in Independence
Hall in September uh 2022 just ahead of
the midterm elections are directed by
Lenny ruifenstall I mean might as well
have been right every everything that
they use that she invented at the
Nuremberg rallies you know putting the
leader up on the pedestal she was the
one who dug trenches put the cameras in
the trenches so you'd be looking up even
higher at the leader the vertical lights
the blood red backdrop everything about
that the art direction that speech was
right out of Nuremberg and you know
she's a great art director
um and and more uh so but what if I
didn't say he said half the country are
enemies of the people he said not all
your Republicans but you Maggie
Republicans well that's Charlie the
Republican Party
um our enemies of the people so now you
got Biden telling you you're An Enemy of
the State you got the government knowing
actually it's kind of thought control
because I using inference I can tell by
what you're reading what you're buying
what you're attending Etc kind of what
you're thinking uh combine that with
artificial intelligence and GPT
technology and now you got a Target on
your back and expect to knock on the
door from the FBI goon squads so that's
also a bike fragility
that's where we're going yeah but so
look so that being the case but let's
look at it in practical so you've got
the dollar which is pretty much a
digital currency and so is this Sterling
as where we are now correct so that's
just digital currency we've got a cbdc
what is the difference is the CD cbdc is
that going to be a new currency or is
that just going to be the dollar
and if there is a dollar how are they
going to transition from everybody using
this system to everybody using cbdc well
the transition is already underway
there's a new best comforting gym yeah
oh sorry
um you know and and you know when you
frame a question like you know can we
bring this down to the everyday American
or Brit or citizen around the world I
completely agree with that that's a good
approach but what I am talking to that
audience I'm talking to you but I I
understand the audience I'm saying if
the elites are working on uh something
that would make George Orwell blush
which it would that is something that
affects Everyday People you ought to pay
attention to that
um and the difference
um Francis is
as essential meditation current is not a
new currency it's still a dollar or
still a Euro or still you want or
whatever it's a new payment Channel but
here are the differences number one
here's the biggest one the government
controls the Ledger not MasterCard not
Visa the government controls the Ledger
and right now see MasterCard has product
codes uh and so um uh you know there's
like probably book skip to anyone like
you know retail or you know consumer
durables they're kind of broad
categories they do sort them that way
and they give your your own statement
and all that but interestingly
MasterCard recently came up with a
separate code for
um guns guns and ammunition now it used
to be Sporting Goods yeah you wouldn't
necessarily know if I bought a fly rod
or a AR-15 but now you will because they
they break it out and I was at the
government's behals that's the beginning
but you'll see that in extreme form with
Central Bank digital currencies they're
going to know what you're buying correct
uh but yes but from that with artificial
intelligence they can know what you're
that's really my point
um but um you know combine that with uh
you know the you know these other other
developments are taking place but the
FED is rolling on a system called uh fed
now uh it's going into kind of testing
uh in a few months actually I think this
summer uh they've announced this and uh
this is the inner Bank version so it's
not going to be on my smartphone or it's
not going to be at retail yet but they
want to make sure it all works between
the banks the inner Bank payment system
and then they'll kind of roll it up but
they also got a bit of cash because you
say all right I don't like this system I
don't want them knowing what books I'm
buying whatever
um I'm going to use cash so you got to
get rid of cash you're seeing that
already how many places you've seen no
cash accepted so so they'll do that
um and then the other thing they got to
whack is Bitcoin now I'm not a Bitcoin
fan but you know it is what it is if
people want to knock yourself out but
that's not good enough for the
government so going back to our banking
crisis discussion on the same night uh
Sunday March 12th when they said all the
deposits are protected they also waxed
Signature Bank they took out a bank
called Signature Bank and Barney Barney
Frank was on the board of directors Us
in Dodd-Frank you know so they've been
doing a lot of good but Frank said and
he was correct he said if you had just
let us go until Monday when the FED
announced Sunday night that they would
buy all the underwater bonds at par we
would have been fine why did you take us
out why were we any different than any
other medium-sized bank which were all
in the same condition the answer is they
had a portal going back to my Casino
metaphor to the crypto world called
Cygnet and they were very active in
converting cryptocurrencies into
mainstream banking they were regular
Bank member Bank ftse insured but they
had this portal between the backing
world and the crypto world and that's
what they were that's what they wanted
to kill and that's why they took out
Signature Bank and didn't give them one
Day's Grace to to survive so they got to
whack Bitcoin they got to whack cash and
I would say if you want to slaughter
cattle you got heard him into the
slaughterhouse get them in the pen and
get them in a shoot well you got to get
rid of cash and crypto hurt everybody
into the digital world then you can
whack them politically and that's what's
going on okay Jim uh we go to wrap up
but before we do our final question and
our locals question there is an obvious
question here which is if you're an
ordinary person listening to this
and you haven't jumped out of a window
yet what do you do about it
well a couple things and this gets back
I guess I digressed a little bit when I
was to have gold in your portfolio
um and going back further to the reserve
currency thing there is there is no
alternative to the dollar as a reserve
currency in terms of bond markets
there's no bond market with all you know
derivatives and Futures and options and
settlement clearance and rule of law and
all that stuff but there is an
alternative called gold so gold will be
where countries go and it should be
where investors go uh follow the money
as they say and uh central banks have
been net buyers for the last 13 years so
they're about the best informed players
you can imagine so I'd have some gold
for that reason because not because it's
shiny and pretty but because
um central banks are are huge net buyers
and it is the alternative to the dollar
there's no other currency that comes
close but gold does so that's the reason
to have have some gold in your portfolio
and also this loss of confidence and
dollar that we've been talking about
independent of what other countries are
doing
um it'll it'll preserve wealth it'll
it'll be fine the next day uh you know
if there's some kind of Panic or
collapse or revulsion against the dollar
that's how currencies die your gold will
hold up just fine and
before we go
do you think they use a pandemic to get
rid of cash
they use the pandemic for a lot of
things and we'll need another hour on
that maybe you can invite me back uh
we'll do that in due course but the
pandemic was a dry run for the climate
change Panic that they're trying to
promote so my biggest shock of the
pandemic when they say where I'm at mass
network the research is clear by the way
these are not opinions I'm happy to give
anybody 50 peer-reviewed academic papers
that back this up messed up where
lockdowns don't work
um the guy who uh won the presidential
medal freedom for eradicating smallpox
wrote a paper in 2006 D.A Henderson
greatest virologist in history said
lockdowns don't work but of course that
was ignored by Anthony fauci because he
had to cover up his own crimes in Wuhan
um but uh so there's a lot of Truth
bombs being dropped in this episode uh
so we we know all this yeah okay but my
point is it was a really good job you
know what shocked me the most not that
the government would lie not that they
would use fear but the people would go
along with it yeah I was the same that's
what shocked me you're wearing a mask
you a cop had to basically cost me to
get me to put a mask on and then as soon
as he was gone I pulled down under my
chin I never wore a mask
um best treatment for covert but I said
get outside get some sunshine fresh air
maybe a little vitamin C exercise lose a
few pounds that was the right therapy
and we did the opposite put a mask on
stay inside so so as a dry run it worked
fear works and people are more obedient
than I would have expected so if those
two things are true then you run the you
run the climate change Playbook and you
you get World control
well uh yeah I mean the fact that people
responded the way they did was
absolutely terrifying yeah and that's
what I always say to people you know
people who complained about the covet
authoritarianism they're like oh yeah
the government went all tyrannical and
and it wasn't Democrat I was like no no
the government was looking at the people
losing their and giving them what
they wanted right now in fairness to the
people they were terrified into it by
the government and the media yeah right
but you put all that together and the
people willing to give away their
freedom correct and that is terrifying
uh and on that happy note uh Jim uh as
always thank you for coming on the show
obviously we recommend everybody check
out sold out among your many other books
and we always end with the same question
which is what's the one thing we're not
talking about as a society that we
really should be
um we're we can actually look everyone's
like AI is the end and charity is the
end of the um search engine which it is
that's why Google is in such a panic and
they're rolling out their AI
um but
we can look Beyond AI to the end of AIA
is the end of the search engine we look
beyond that to Ai and the reason I
promise to be brief we're coming out the
end of a 2 300 year old tunnel Plato was
a transitional figure between the
homeric society Homer never wrote a word
it was all he composed it orally it was
a recital that's how people learned it
it wasn't a poem in their minds it was
the Encyclopedia of Greek behavior
um Plato would start writing things down
using the phonetic alphabet which is
brand new at the time and we've been
using phonetic alphabet ever since we
are now coming out the other end of that
into an oral acoustic tactile society
and Everyone likes emojis they think
they're cute emojis are hieroglyphics
they're not phonic and and the same
thing with you know Universal signs
hip-hop and that thing and Hip-Hop I'm
just saying it's all acoustic and kids
are getting an education they're
absorbing it electronically they're not
sitting in class should be but they're
not so uh that wasn't me for the whole
Computer World where we just taught
chat gbt Transit computer to read a
billion pages of text what does it mean
when we don't read it anymore
what does it mean it means we're not
ingesting it we're not ingesting
information properly well we're
ingesting it in an electronic way you
know Marshall McLaren said when the
first Sputnik went up with the entire
world became a human artifact because we
wrapped it in aluminum foil
um so some of this is just kind of
updating mcluhan for the chat GPT world
but um it's uh
he came up with the phrase Global
Village everyone says oh it sounds kind
of nice Global Village you know he says
no Villages are brutal violent tribal so
it was an accurate description good
choice of words they said don't think
that means warm and fuzzy it's we are
becoming more tribal and that's what
acoustic environment electronic
environment is doing to us and we don't
know it it's um uh you know I would say
the the fish we don't know who
um discovered water but we're sure it
was not the fish because the fish is in
the water you have to take the fish out
of the water it's like oh where's the
water well we're in this electronic
environment we don't even know it yeah
we can do another hour on that as well
and I have no doubt that we will Jim
it's always a pleasure to have you on
the show and that's why you should head
over to locals join us there for the
bonus questions that you've already
submitted that only you will get to see
the answers to take care and see you
soon
will you be putting money on Trump to
win the election next year
[Music]